you okay man you made it
huh
can you hear me Dart yeah I apologize
for that guys it's just so I I left like
an hour and a half ago to get some
errands done and the errands turned out
to be way longer than I originally
anticipated uh you guys should be able
to hear me now I hope so $2 Super Chat
from the angry therapist late late yeah
we late late and I'm sorry man I'm sorry
that we late
late yeah we hear you okay I apologize
for that guys you know normally I try to
be on time for this but sometimes stuff
happens you know you could tell that I
had a crazy day and you know how you
could tell that
DT oh look at the title today for the
show
[Laughter]
just it just it's been oh now my screen
seems to be going out I don't know
that's that's that's future addict prob
what's going on you
guys what's going on you guys welcome to
the adct show we talk about the past
present and future game I got my co-host
with me D gy what's going on D GRE
ah we're almost at the end
it's almost here add the end of
[Laughter]
everything almost at the end of 18month
Journey it's almost
done imagine
like life after that man we feel
completed $2 Super Chat from the anchor
therapist is cool just messing with you
guys I hear you guys but once again you
know I definitely apologize for being
late it just it's been a crazy hectic
day and I've been playing a lot of
persona five like what's funny is you
know before we get into it because this
going to be a pretty relatively uh short
show you know what I've been do I know
this is probably like really bad but you
know how I come up with the the topics
for the show these days what's
that I look with the videos I've made
the past
week because I I just cover so much
stuff these days it's just yeah it's
hard for me not to uh you know really
figure out what's going on all right so
hold up
all right edit this all right so I think
the first topic obviously that
PlayStation
5 it
console increase that's the first one
the second one you know we got to talk
about that uh Xbox deal
closing and the last one we could talk
about is
Halo 5 Halo
Infinite season five season five
yeah all right
saving I appreciate you guys working
with me man I appreciate you guys
working with but all right all right
let's let's go straight to the show
because we already late we already late
we might go straight into the show dirt
please tell me you've been paying
attention to all the stuff that's going
on right now with Halo F Halo Infinite
season five yes I've been paying
attention to it it that trailer looked
amazing
brother yeah it looks like you know for
the most part like they they got they
stuff to they know what they gonna
do yeah think it's G to be interesting I
think so man I think that um you know
because I always hear people bash Halo
infinite but the game released really
good man people tend to forget that
people tend to forget it released as a
87 Metacritic if people go by Metacritic
which a lot of these guys do it released
very good it released polish the
campaign was pretty good um but it was
the only issue was the content
afterwards it was coming out very slow
but now it seems like they're in their
groove they are in a good Groove man and
um Pierre hins I always get is his last
name hint or hins I don't know I don't
know hence
um I'mma say hints um he's hey man they
said that he was the guy that fixed
Master Chief Collection so far this
content is looking pretty good man um
yeah man so halyo listen man the game
still I see people try to bring up steam
numbers hey look at this it's it's dead
on Steam shut up y I want to hear that
we ain't trying to hear that you know
it's it's a Xbox game it's it's on Steam
but it's still doing really well on
console so it's so funny how they
conveniently want to run to steam when
it benefits their narrative like oh stop
it stop it funny they want talk about
the steam PlayStation numbers to oh they
don't want to talk man there was a guy
that said yo look at the look at h on
Steam and then this guy had responded to
him he he put every PlayStation
exclusive on Steam and uh yeah that
wasn't it wasn't good it doesn't look
good man you know it's definitely one of
those things that I find hilarious that
like a lot of the the hardcore
PlayStation people don't want to talk
about that yeah it's like you
your your thing is so like the brand is
so strong it doesn't sell on anything
but PlayStation and if you really think
about it like the vast majority of
people that buy games on PlayStation
they're still like buying only like 2%
two to 5% of like the actual install
base unless you're like a god of war or
something then you know that's going to
be a little bit higher but for the most
part like what did returnal sell like
like a
million overall yeah I think no I think
it was under a million I'm not sure
um let me see something you know there's
a couple comments in the chat get them
no no like some of them aren't bad but
Mike Johnson said it had a lot missing
it did have some stuff missing 100% but
the core game that dropped was still
pretty solid the multiplayer was pretty
solid yes they had some stuff me missing
like Co-Op campaign and Forge and some
other stuff that was previously in the
games when they dropped but I don't
think that's just a Halo issue if you
look at today's games a lot of games
drop missing stuff man so let's stop
acting like it's just Halo bro stop it
stop you
know I can't gaming problem not a Halo
problem I'm sorry but go ahead there
there's some developers that's done it
better but for the most part like you
know when we just compare launch they
had a good launch yeah they did they had
a good launch Man the game you know the
game play has always been solid it's
just you know it was definitely missing
some
modes I always felt like what they
should have done and this is just me
personally when I was playing Gear uh
let me get this Super Chat real quick I
don't know what currency that is maybe
you know I have no idea uh but uh 50 uh
mock student
4364 love your videos guys thank you for
the amazing content appreciate it man
appreciate it I'm say so you say no no I
agree game shouldn't be missing
anything but that's the world we live in
today I'm not just C he wasn't defending
it he was saying it's not a Halo issue
it's an industry issue I'm not right I'm
not defending Halo I'm not bro okay you
want to talk that
smack come up in here talk listen
Battlefield launched
terrible Battlefield launch's terrible
but I still feel that Halo gets more
stuff than Battlefield
does so I mean there's so many games
that launch unfinished broken I mean
like like these games with multiplayer
some games without multiplayer people
you know talk about games like you know
um like like what's the game um Star
Wars Jedi surviv that launched shaky it
wasn't a single player game it wasn't
really missing stuff but they adding
modes later they're adding 60 FPS modes
they're adding stuff that should have
been in the game and launch so this is
not just a Halo or a battlefield issue
it's a gaming industry issue right now
let's be real about
that Co silver hand said where it's
factions yeah ain't nobody want to talk
about that you what's funny about when
it comes to the faction thing I'm still
I'm still waiting for you Forte you know
you come in here with all all type of
ain't missing nothing but when I say
where you at you ain't nowhere no I'm
joking for look at the end of the day I
I do feel like because when I played the
story of Halo infinite I felt like and
maybe I'm wrong you know may maybe it's
a me problem uh but you know at the very
beginning when they were doing
the okay there was like a map on Halo
infinite and you know I felt like they
should have divide cuz CU part of the
mystery is what happened that led
led to Chief being defeated you know
what I'm saying so I felt like they
should have separated that map kind of
like they did in Fallout uh in Far Cry 5
and every a part of the map should have
been dedicated to another part of the
banish like a general like and imagine
like when you start doing it it does a
backstory it's like this is what he did
this is this is how he fought against it
and it's like this is one of the key
components that led to the Marines
losing that
war yeah yeah like every like porson you
know have like a different boss
something yeah yeah I just think that
would have been like really solid like
that that's just me personally and you
know U you have to do enough C Havoc
where you know his Elite troops come out
you know what I'm saying like I I just
felt like Halo infinite story was fun it
just felt very Foundation like it didn't
feel like it was filled in a lot hey let
me ask you something because I saw
somebody mention Destiny in the chat how
did Destiny
release not a lot of
content you know Destiny actually here
recently the past couple years they've
gotten better at telling a story but
initially they were they were really bad
at that too like they having a really
hard time doing anything really in the
whole home the whole gaming
space all right question like that's a
question because it still feels like
Halo gets it more than any other title
any other franchise honestly and I think
it's because people expect more from
Halo to a point like it's one of those
big uh gaming icons that it could that
could be completely not justified but at
the same time you know I would rather be
a brand that people expect more from me
than a brand that people expect nothing
from like
factions like oh my God actually you
know what we gonna talk about that too
because uh we really talk about that
last week did we yeah because we missed
missed last week um Faxon was a big
topic for a couple weeks yeah yeah we G
talk about that and you know I want to
apologize to the people for last week
too let me give you a brief summary I
was just burned out I I didn't get a lot
of sleep the night before you know it it
was just like I woke up I made that
video that day and I was like would get
me like an hour or two sleep before the
attic show and then I woke up like 30
minutes before I felt horrible I my
sinuses were going crazy and I'm like I
I need to take take take a me day I was
like it was I I was struggling I wanted
to talk you know I love to come in here
and talk that smack with that factions
of dirt but it's just like that energy
was gonna be there and I just didn't
know if I could realistically keep that
energy going in there man yeah I wanted
to man I want to I get it bro because I
do uh I I damn near do podcast five days
a week now bro it's like I got two on my
channel I do this one I do one on you my
boy Sean Chan on Friday so really the
only day I'm really off is for
Tuesdays and that's why I
to after this one bro where you going
after this one uh like you know like one
of the homies Ray Ray he got a little
podcast he asked me y I said yeah I come
on man so I'm like when's it start um I
think 8 o'clock my time okay so you have
a little bit of time yeah gota give me
something in between yeah that's why I
tried to get you up out of here in like
an hour talk no I actually appreciate
that bro because if your podcast would
be like two and a half hours every
Wednesday I don't know if I'd be able to
do it bro yeah we the only time we ever
hit two hours is when it's been a crazy
week and part of the reason it's only an
hour hour and a half tops is because we
only stick to us two we rarely have a
third person in there now obviously if
there's like a really good interesting
topic and we can have a good perspective
of third person I'll bring a third
person on here but I'm be real with you
I don't want to deal with a third person
I'm be keep it a buck I do a podcast
called Planet Xbox with smooth all the
time and every time in the chat people
like why don't you get a third person
here because I don't want to deal with a
third person it's hard enough dealing
with when smooth can do something you
want to add a third entity onto that
yeah no thank you yeah I got you bro and
not to I do do a podcast every week that
is like three podcast everyone does
every week it is bro
your onla will go two hours before I hit
the first topic I be like how Yen
officially announced it yet but we got
these chairs now oh those sweet bro yeah
um it's I can't I don't know the
name uh they said all the members of
i1 it is called
called hor
worth uh uh okay I'm going to put
the okay this is the pronunciation
someone tell me how to pronounce that
you guys know I can't pronounce for
nothing and that's
fine see see if here's the thing here's
the difference between me and other
people it's harder to troll me because I
come out openly admit it I'm like my
pronunciation is trash so what you going
to do I have
I have weaponized myself I took the
bullets out of your chamber you shooting
blanks because I got the
weapon yeah so uh you know but this
thing is like interesting like it I feel
like at first when you look at it
because it's smaller than my last one it
doesn't really look like it's going to
support my weight you know what I'm
saying like it's got this like real Hall
War Hall Warth okay whatever Hall Warth
it's got like this lumbar support and
like this thing could go back like crazy
it it really be convincing me that I'm
gonna break it look at this oh oh there
you
go that's why I don't be doing that
very yeah so it it's just you know we
got a lot of a show to talk about though
so let's move on heyo there's not like a
whole lot to talk about Halo INF I do
think that we're going to see some
really
good you know strains forward I I hope
that they're able to
use
the the uh the momentum that Halo
infinite's giving where we could slowly
maybe just maybe May Maybe I'm Wrong DT
but maybe we could see you know a full
because right now I think we're in that
weird spot where Microsoft doesn't know
if they want to because when you own
stuff like Call of Duty stuff like um
Elder Scrolls Fallout out you don't need
Halo front and center anymore so I think
that's what they're looking at they're
like do we really need this right now
and uh you know I'm I'm concerned for
that you know I I want Halo to always be
around maybe not in the way that we see
it but I do want the Halo brand to be
around I disagree with you though anic I
believe they know they still need Halo
it's just that because they have those
other IPS they can definitely take their
Time with Halo and the 360 generation
was Hal over every three years like
clockwork infinite took longer um but I
don't think there you know there's going
to do consistent content hopefully
they'll do a new campaign because I
would love a new campaign with atrio if
you saw the end of um Halo infinite
campaign I really do want them to do
another campaign but I just feel that
it's just they know Halo is still
important to Xbox and they want that
they want Doom they want Call of Duty
they want Wolfenstein they want Halo
they want all of those franchises to
remain relevant I think the reason that
I say that they know they don't
necessarily need Halo it's not that
they've always needed Halo to carry the
whole ship you know what I'm saying like
yeah they did in the past I think now
Halo can just be one of like the engines
it don't got to be the ship anymore yeah
I agree with that yeah it could be one
of
they need them anymore yeah I I think
that's probably their mindset it's like
not necessarily we don't need Halo we
don't need Halo to Define Xbox anymore
we need we need Halo to be a solid
experience that that drives people to
our platform but I would say they look
at more stuff like Elder Scrolls you
know Starfield stuff like that they're
like they're looking on equal terms as
Halo like we're gonna make sure that
these games all deliver and they come
together and form the The Infinity
Gauntlet Stop PlayStation away like see
I agree with that but at first I thought
you were saying that Xbox felt they like
they don't need Halo because I didn't
agree with that but I do agree with what
you're saying they have all these huge
franchises bro like you said it become
The Infinity Gauntlet bro and
just I I do think their biggest thing is
they are
worried on maybe we they overreached
with Halo too much and maybe if this
next Halo doesn't doesn't Captivate it
doesn't bring more the audience back I
do think we will see probably a whole
like all Next Generation no Halo the
whole generation I think they'll put
that on the shelves for at least three
to five years just just so people will
forget the 343 Reign because the 343
don't do it this next game um they'll
still be called I don't know they might
even change the name I don't because
here's the thing like people like you
got to get rid of 343 the people that
can handle Halo
to what you expect Halo the only company
right now is
343 uh the problem is is the management
is you know I feel like sometimes they
don't know how they want to uh Halo to
be I've always felt like it I don't know
how about you feel DT I've always felt
like they've let the the community make
Halo they've never stuck to their own
guns every time they do something and
the community don't like it they'll pull
back and do something else okay you
don't you don't like our our vision for
Halo 5 we're gonna abandon all that and
start again with Halo
infinite um I don't know um I feel I
feel that 343 they get a bad repap
because they're not Bungie now they not
Halo funny is the people that say why
isn't Bungie making Halo they're the
ones that hate
Destiny it's funny how that goes but
with me personally I love Halo 4
campaign but I didn't care much for the
multiplayer for part five I love the
multiplayer I thought the campaign was
average exactly same and I thought me
logically thinking you've made the
you've made the best exp the best Halo
it could be it's just you you put
sections in every game like take take
the single player narrative aspect for
four take the multiplayer and Define it
for five slot that stuff together like a
p butter and jelly sandwich you got you
got it it's good you got dinner like
what you mean don't go down this route
Forte what do you mean don't go down
this route because my opinion with my
route I mean the route is is my opinion
I is that the real Forte first off yeah
I think it is yeah he's he's moded
that's the real Forte Forte you gonna
have to come in here yo you you I feel I
feel like Crossfire is starting to is is
starting to seep into you man I feel
like Crossfire is starting to seep into
you hanging around ponies would do that
man he going have to be more specific on
what he mean by that because I I gotta
know what we what we gonna call addict
what oh we got black
lavender yeah they call me black
lavender call me white
Coke oh my goodness that's a couple
super chats man yeah let's let's let's
uh let's let's get the super chat we got
a $10 Super Chat from Adidas 20 Sony
laughed at the Xbox One when they
announced a media box 10 years later
Sony selling nothing but devices and no
games they're trying to recuperate the
Cod money already what do you feel about
that what do you feel about that's the
homie Adidas 20 he'll be TTS and he be
talking that I actually agree with him
and I don't know if they're trying to
recuperate the Call of Duty
money but I really think it and maybe
I'm wrong maybe I'm and I'm fine with
that but I truly believe we're going to
get to the
point where people are going to refer
Jim
Ryan as the PlayStation Dawn
matrick yeah it's gonna look like that
man C because to me I feel like in a
year year and a half once more info
comes out they're be like dude whoever
takes over the next I mean you gotta
look where where he came in from okay
they had no games they put all their
money in investing into into games as a
service and almost none of those
succeeded like this dude was inherited a
broken ship from Jim R bro you listen
whoever gets because you know all of
those games at the service they're not
going to cancel them they already in
development for the most part so for you
g have to come up in here if you want if
you want to keep fighting like you have
to come in here part of the problem
listen man I I don't care bro I'm not
saying 3 fo three is perfect man nobody
is saying that I'm saying I like Halo
4 I like Halo 5 multiplayer and I enjoy
Halo infinite campaign and multiplayer
I'm not saying they're perfect I'm not
saying they're better than Bungie I'm
just telling you what I liked and what I
didn't like yeah he he never even
remotely said that he liked it he he he
just said the certain aspects of Halo I
like on one game and there's certain
aspects of Halo I liked on others I
don't know what you want to talk about I
mean I'm not defending 343 I didn't say
they were perfect I actually was
defending 343 if you want to get
technical look Bungie has issues uh 343
has issues but I feel like a lot of
that's management it's not the studio
it's not the devs you know and keep in
mind Forte
man do I really want to say this yeah I
do I do for I know more about what's
going on at 343 IND is in YouTu I'm not
saying you don't know nothing but I'm
saying I know I know things okay I know
things please do what you talking about
you said you gonna come up in
here Forte Forte Forte you GNA come in
here and fight with me huh I don't know
man I I I I've been I've been doing my
jogging here lately I feel like I'm in
good shape right now Forte I'm in good
shape I don't know if you want that
smoke I don't know man I might be able
to talk for a whole two minutes without
breathing I don't know if you want that
smoke all right let me get these super
chats while Forte decides if he's gonna
if he's gonna run or not5 superat from
drawn TJ hi guys Sean internet was trash
this morning so I told him PlayStation
is selling you a router it's the
PlayStation 5 Slim oh you call the
Slimmer
router as long as like the Aesthetics
look pleasing I do think it's going to
be a better thing than the current one
we have
now because that PlayStation 5 like the
physical Edition it's just too
big it is it's it it how like so big
that when I have it right here it
literally blocks it's like right
here it comes up to like right here on
my camera I have to move it I can't have
it here see here see what people don't
know my Xbox is right
here it's under it but see you you don't
know that because it's short enough
where it's off camera not the
PlayStation that that [__] is in the
middle of
it oh Forte is here let me get these
super chats before we pull him up in
here okay $5 Super Chat from the angry
therapist MD IOP is a full work day plus
overtime I love it though I appreciate
you know we know let me let me point
something clear I never in my Dre dream
expected that show to be that long but
you know it is what it is okay let me
get this real quick we got uh five Super
Chat from Jay rbert people got to give
Pete Hines a chance he's only been the
studio you had for a year I
think Pete Hines uh we'll see we'll see
Pete uh no you talking about P hin oh P
hence is that someone PlayStation no no
it's guy from 343 okay oh oh yeah this
that replaced um what's his name yeah
all right all right all right
Forte I'm even I'm even blow it up and
put you on the the highend so oh I get I
get I get the full picture okay you get
the full pict picture I'm gonna pet my
kitty you talk oh man real rat you got
there hey don't call my cat a rat this
is a cute rat okay you wish you had a
rat that look like this look at that
look at those eyes cat's making me itch
man that's
all you think I'm allergic to him I'm
just messing with you first of all how
are you guys doing today great show
you're having
today what's happening what's on
your nothing on M mind man I'm just just
listening there's definitely something
on your mind no man everybody knows how
listen man everybody knows Halo is like
the soft spot for me man it's like
whenever someone I'm not saying y'all
ain't right because the game is actually
really good now I played it recently um
and I really like the direction they're
going in I just can't get over the fact
of how that game was treated two years
ago man I it's nothing anybody can tell
me that that game should have came out
like yes the campaign was good I
actually liked that I beat it I played
the multiplayer multiplayer was fine but
there was just too many things that was
like that game should not have been it
should have been celebrated it shouldn't
have been like oh it's missing this or
or has this or this is an issue yeah it
was just so many things about that game
that just should not have happened that
just made me upset at just Direction and
I still feel to this day that that game
was brought out in
2021 just so they can actually celebrate
a 20th
anniversary if it was no anniversary the
game probably would have got push back a
little bit further and they probably
would have waited until more of the
stuff comes out but that's just my own
little you know ttim F hat opinion so I
don't it's not that I dislike I don't
it's not that I disagree with you guys
on it it's just
that with that game being literally the
second most my second favorite game of
all time behind Mass Effect I just have
a high standard for that game and I feel
like it just hasn't been lived up to at
least for the last two games you know I
think Halo Halo 4 was actually really
good I think people get that a bad rap
just because the multiplayer didn't
stand up on like like you know previous
Halos and I think that was just their
first forway into actually getting into
it but the campaign was amazing like
some of the best it's still one of the
best looking Xbox 360 games that looked
really like if you played it today and
they and it looks great um Halo 5 is a
whole another issue I don't think the
game was a problem I just think the
marketing was just terrible around that
game but it just didn't do they they
didn't do any favors it's not that it's
just a 343 problem it's a Xbox problem
with that franchise I just feel like at
a certain point just like what are we
doing why why is this game of all your
games the one that is like the
sacrificial lamb when it comes to like
the overall quality of it because Halo's
always been about that and it just seems
like recently not even recently for like
the last two to three games that's been
a problem and I never will ever say that
because of Halo isn't made by Bungie
because I think Bungie has their own
issues and I didn't even like I gave
Destiny crap when it first came out
because the game was nowhere near what
it was supposed to be and I was looking
forward to Master Chief Collection
coming out in 2014 and literally being
the game that was like okay when M Chief
comes out in November I'm out I'm not
playing Dy no more I'm getting out of
here and then we know what happened with
that game and that was kind of that was
kind of it for me when it came for Halo
and just My
overall like trust in 343 with it
because I felt like Halo 4 was good
Master Chief Collection was a complete
disaster and I don't understand how that
even happened Halo 5 they just didn't
live up to whatever expectations they
planned for people to believe in what
the campaign was and then Halo infinite
just wasn't the game that it should have
been at launch it should have been it
should have been celebrated not malign
because of the things that was missing
and that was mostly due to Xbox putting
the game out instead of just letting
that game cook a little bit longer was
the game good yeah because Halo was
always a good game it's nothing really
wrong with it I just hate not I don't
even want to say word hate because I
don't want to make it seem like I hate
that you said what you said it's just
that people celebrate that
game like it was really nothing wrong
with it and it's like no it was issues
with that game I didn't say it was
nothing wrong with it no not you not you
not this this is just my overall this is
just my overall thing I think he's just
saying you know it wasn't necessarily
directed towards you it was his issue
with how the community handles Hal
infinite he was just voicing his opinion
all that in general but what what's your
what's your response to that D well the
community k it was Halo infinite for
whatever reason like I said I'm not I'm
not saying the game was perfect I
thought the game launched um in a decent
state was it missing stuff obviously yes
it was missing a lot of things now Forte
you mentioned Destiny 2 you cuss them
out at launch but eventually you went on
to play that game a lot right yeah there
nothing else like meaning the game kind
of redeemed itself Redemption right it
kind of okay I got over I I got okay
okay perfect example you should have
seen his face when you said okay okay
but you got a bunch of hours in that
game though right only be
listen I this this story's been told
multiple times I'm trying to tell you if
Master Chief Collection was the game it
was supposed to be at launch my time in
Destiny with nowhere in beaten is what
it is right now okay that was the only
because listen I always tell people
Destiny is the perfect Evolution to what
Halo used to be it's a faster version of
it the Gunplay and gam play is
phenomenal but there's there was think
about 2014 there was nothing on the
market that came close to what a proper
Halo experience was to what Destiny was
so it was like either hey just stop
playing games like that all together or
play Call of Duty Battlefield 4 was out
but Battlefield 4 was still having this
issues and I was still playing that off
and on and being a main shooter it was
like okay massach Chief Collection is
unplayable pretty much and then we have
Destiny so if you want your sci-fi kick
that's kind of where you're going to go
so Destiny actually benefited for the
fact that bun well not Bungie 343
dropped the ball with Halo infinite well
Halo uh Master Chief Collection so
that's where my disdain came now I will
instantly tell people yes Destiny
redeemed itself but it wasn't because
they had it it was no other option and
we always say that why did Destiny get
so big because there was no other
options like that out there okay now is
so much competition would Destiny still
Thrive like it's thriving now if it had
the competition that it has now probably
not it will still probably do good
because it has the name of Bungie behind
it and Bungie still lives off the Halo
IP so yeah it will probably be decently
good but a lot of people only give that
game a try or even play it because of
the the pedigree they built from another
game that they don't have anything to do
with anymore so once Halo dropped the
ball it was kind of easy to transfer
over but I understand what you're saying
but it's just it's kind of in my case
it's a different unique situation why I
kept playing one over the other okay um
well listen all of this is your opinion
my op opinion you know that's all it is
so you know there's nothing um crazy but
I just feel that Halo
infinite released it wasn't a broken
game it was just missing stuff it was
just missing some stuff that should have
been and now all of those things are
there I know it's two years later all of
those things are there and some right
they brought all back the stuff that was
missing at launch I just feel
that if like the people that say Halo
infinite was a mess and all of that
stuff okay fine that's what you want to
say but we can
say in your opinion you know yeah Bungie
had a Redemption story we can say cyber
Punk had a Redemption story but when it
comes to Halo some people now you
admitted that the game is is great you
played it recently but some people not
you necessarily but some people still
want to say yo Halo is bad and they
still living off of what happened two
years ago in their eyes and I'm like yo
man if you hated the game because it
didn't have the same people will give
props to no man sky and to all these
other games for turning
around because those areans people say
if you said halo you know didn't have
this stuff you know when it launched
Halo 343 is dog [__] blah blah blah then
when Halo is at the state it is now
people like yo man people looking
forward like yo haloon five looks hype
so why is it that it's still getting
that yeah it looks fine but because
those aren't fans I yes I get that but
that's that's listen when I say the
things what when I when I say what I say
I'm saying it from a fans perspective
I'm not saying it because I hate 343 and
anything like that I'm saying it from a
perspective of how well up until listen
it was kind of he's over here he's over
here straight up lying why you me adct
listen me and adct didn't had this
conversation in the background me and
three for three I just do not get that
studio and all the things that happen
over there because I feel like it's ASD
ey but no I will give them the dub when
the dub needs to be given and the game
when I played it for the first time like
a couple weeks ago I was like yo this
game feels really good but like you said
with cyber Punk cyber Punk yes people
are G to give it a Redemption it
shouldn't get one but people are going
to give it I'm never see this the thing
I'm never going to be the person that's
going to tell somebody that just because
the game is better now means you should
forget what happened in the past cyber
Punk was utterly unplayable for a lot of
people in the beginning yeah I actually
got into like I had a lot of people
attack me because I said even cyberpunk
has turned it around it's still a very
debatable subject if that game should be
supported at all for what they came out
as it and guess what and I bought like
perfect example I bought Master Chief
Collection day one day one when it came
out I haven't you know how many times I
installed that game on my system and
wanted to play it and literally went to
click the icon to do it and then said no
I can't do
it I'm not GNA lie about that it is all
because of the one it it's not that the
game's not good I know that game's great
but in my mind I feel like it took you
four three to four years to get the game
to where it is
now so I just don't want to ambitious
exact definitely a little bit and that's
what and that's thing I said why why be
so ambitious about it just make the game
separate so you can have different
Hoppers instead of trying to do this
cross play thing where you can like jump
from one I mean it was a cool concept I
really thought if it worked it would
have been amazing I I do give them
Prosper trying to you know Usher a new
way of playing multiplayer forward that
was a great idea but if you can't do it
don't do it especially with that
franchise
because that's what PE that's the reason
people at that point were playing Xbox
for it was about Halo it was about Gears
of War steel it was about all those
first party titles that people were
still in love with the whole Halo gears
in Forza and now they don't really have
to worry about that and and and I agree
with adct earlier they don't have to
really worry about that now because they
have so many other IPS it might have
been you D I'm say I don't want to give
adct your shy but they don't have to
worry about that now as much because
they have that's fine whatever you and
that cat but um they they don't have to
worry about it as much now as they did
then because now they have other IPS and
other development houses they can lean
on so I definitely want them to give
Halo basically a really really good wide
birth until they do something else I
want to see what the campaign does if
you play the end of
infinite I want I want to see the end of
that I do but I don't want to see the
end of it at the detriment of them not
getting it right the first time and not
just with the campaign the whole thing
as a whole because I feel like Halo is
one of those games that you should treat
with it should have reverence every time
you speak of it when people talk about
Halo it should be like yo Halo's just as
good now as it was in 2017 when they had
Billboards lit up in Time Square for it
that's how we should be thinking of that
game not how we not it shouldn't even be
a divide on that game and that and
that's how I feel about it but go I
don't know what what you about to say DK
um no no no I I mean I'm just listening
to uh like what you're saying and like I
said it it's all subjective this is your
opinion I have my opinion so um I
understand what you're saying I just
feel that you know I don't want to play
the
it's a Xbox first party game card I
really don't yeah please don't sometimes
but sometimes it seems like when it's
the Xbox first party they get
scrutinized worse than any other game
you know what I think it actually is D I
think it's not because it's an XBox
exclusive you know as far as like not
the PlayStation people because obviously
the PlayStation people gon hate
regardless right exactly I think the
reason people are so hard on Halo in
particular is because it's a very love
friend anch and people get very upset I
mean think about it like you know even
factions factions pretty much getting
can canned at this point we'll goe and
move on to that now we we oh yeah we
could definitely talk about that but
yeah that he made he made a really good
point and you got move it over from
there Halo for me I went out and bought
first it was a PC game if everybody
remembers it was it got announced at Mac
world it was going to be a PC exclusive
well it's going to be apple yeah apple
exclusive then it was going to be over
the PC I actually went out and bought a
voodoo 500 card because it was only on
PC and I was like dude I want to play
this game I went and bought the graphics
card that had the marketing on the back
of the graphics card for that game and
then literally the next year Microsoft
Xbox wasn't even on the radar no
Microsoft product at all and then Xbox
went out and bought them and not even
caring about what Xbox did I bought a
Xbox day one for that game didn't know
what Xbox was doing doing all I know is
you got the rock up here selling Xboxes
and you got and you got you got um you
got what's name pulling the cape off of
the Xbox at the um at the uh at the
reveal and everything and I'm sitting
there like I don't care about what this
Xbox looks like I just want to play Halo
he you know and that's what it was about
back then you know what's a funny I told
the story before but me personally you
know me the bot that I am right when I
first heard about the Hal I was not
interest I about Xbox I was not
interested at all I I'm a PS2 guy nobody
care about on Microsoft console blah
until I played it I played on my boy
house and I said yo this console is fire
I bought one maybe about six seven
months later and that's when I became a
bot but I see what you say yeah came out
the ended it all the next year oh my God
my first time playing line I don't know
what to do I think just a lot of it in
general just has to do with you know and
obviously there's going to be haters
like there's no denying that there's
going to be haters but I think a lot of
it
when it comes to the core audience they
just they remember Halo back in the Halo
3 days and that you know Halo to Halo
Reach which is funny because a lot of
the issues people have Halo Reach
actually start messing up with and I
think that's what they generally want
I'm not saying that we can never get
those days because I do think that
that's definitely a possibility it's
just I think people need to be very
realistic with you know those days back
then it was easier for games like Halo
to thrive right than it is for people
now yeah I agree with that
100% Focus so yeah I was trying to get
the focus of my head but it's not doing
it is this all right so I think it's
focusing it's focusing on the Batman
sign on your
chest take your glasses off and let it
focus on your eye for a
second oh do you got manual you will
focus on no I don't that's
weird look man it looks at you said
that's a pretty man no matter what so
matter it's like I'm I'm not looking at
you I'm looking through super you want
me to get the super chat why
you put them on the screen or or or you
can get yeah you go read them I'll put
them on the screen um a rodus with the
five Forte my good brother it is 2023
stop the 2021 narrative by Halo is good
now yeah two years later
congratulations two years later
congratul guess what guess what that
game is probably what what can we buy it
for right now $29.99 so I we paid full
price and got half a game at launch okay
a snap man you make other Inc you piss
other zc off man um Adidas 20 to five
fans should judge the game as it is
instead of talking about how they want
it to be over critiquing is a big
problem in gaming you you go man I agree
with that God Emperor sofa king with the
five all life service go down this path
no content and launch besides fortnite
Destiny was broken twice D1 and D2 sh D2
broke right
now it is seven years in is broke well
10 years in almost damn and I think a
lot of it just has to do with just the
Landscaping of the industry right now I
I do agree to a point that the industry
complains about too much stuff that they
don't necessarily know what's going on
but influencers consumers that's their
right you know we don't we're not we
don't get access to the majority of the
industry that helps us make educated
opinions on stuff or it's like and
that's why so many people have hot takes
because we're ignorant in the matter for
the most part you know people sit there
they say oh Halo infinite this Halo
infinite that Microsoft Xbox fo how
about you releasee a documentary on what
happened with 343 but they would never
do something like that but I guarantee
you never do they came out openly about
the development of Halo infinite people
would be more understanding on why it
took so long why we got the product what
we
got yeah yeah you're right that's why I
never argue the fact about what I think
it is versus what we know know PS is
down apparently PlayStation is not
PlayStation network is
all right so let's get on the faction J
cut the cable before he oh man what
going we're 47 minutes in we put that in
the time stamps
factions has been put on ice
ice hey I just got a um somebody just
tagged me it's some I guess he's some
type of Insider named the tipster I
don't know if you guys seen him oh God
some he has some information about it
what okay about what about factions okay
read it to us you good I can read it to
you guys okay Jim Ryan con of gave a
bunch of Studios request to make these
type of games naughty dog had long
considered the idea of doing factions
too but the idea evolved into something
more ultimately it seems like they were
struggling with making the game they
wanted to make in the games as a service
form Bungie were involved but not in the
way people have said Bund are at
PlayStation studio now so they'll be
involved in a large percentage of other
PlayStation Studios games over 200000
people worked on the Last of Us two for
example part two for example it seems
that naughty dog just weren't happy with
the game and their considering just
moving the parts they were happy with
into the last of us three rather than
putting out a separate title that
lessens the brand image in their own
eyes so don't know how true this is this
is a um this is from a guy named the
tipster I guess maybe he had some stuff
before so I don't know how believable
though it does I think that's pretty
much the case and it's just like you
know people want to sit there and say
and I think from a a standpoint when it
comes to you know the mindset of someone
like if Bungie really like especially a
well-known company like nauy do and they
sitting there they got this and then
punch popped in be like yo that's
trash oh no the the game play is fun
yeah but we ain't Mone Ain funding that
you can't make no money with this one
Mak money I do understand to a point on
how that would upset Naughty Dog shout
out to over 500 people in the chat hit
that like button guys let's get those
likes up man let's get those likes upout
out to the chat I do understand that but
at the same
time bun bun was bought for like 3.3 or2
billion 3.6
3.6 billion with a
b and then people are gonna people are
gonna sit here and say USD yeah people
are gonna sit here and say who's it was
bought with
Yen be a lot less if they bought it with
Yen it would be a lot less than
3.6 yeah so I
think I think when you spend that kind
of money
and one of the first games that they
consult on is is factions because that
was probably one of the biggest hype
moments that that was going into that
and when you have that kind of money
behind a studio and bunge's just like
that's not it
PlayStation I I think I don't
necessarily think that they were
responsible for it I think what happened
was they made Bungie went in there did
their analysis went back to place
station was like here's what we like
here's what we don't like and here's
what we think's going to be problems and
when naughty dog followed back up they
are a single player Studio company
they've never worked with games as a
service so when it came to defending
their logic and why they're doing
something like this and and the and that
Bungie doesn't think it will work out
who do you think is going to have a
better argument the person that's been
doing it for 10 years or the person that
does do games as a service for the most
part yeah so I think I just think that
they didn't have anything to say to
convince him it was just like okay this
is what Bungie said what's your what's
your reval they
right it's like what am I to say I don't
know I like it I think the game plays
cool but what that they said you can't
make money here we probably can't like
hey hey you know add he can I say
something right quick I'm going to be
absolutely 100% honest I believe
PlayStation they've made single player
games they're they're some of the best
at making single player games that's my
opinion next to Rockstar they're pretty
much up there Naughty Dog
specifically um I think that when I
think PlayStation singlehandedly saw the
gaming industry
changing and they didn't do nothing
about it
meaning they saw the gaming industry
moving to more games out the service um
monetization and they just sat there and
continued to make single player games
because I like I said they're really
good at it they didn't pivot quick
enough they didn't pivot quick enough we
always hear the example of of uhh
Blackberry right they would have went
out and got those Studios like five 10
years ago yeah and those Studios have
been nurturing these online experiences
from then then maybe this was a
different thing but you know they didn't
do that yeah it exactly I was like I was
about to say the uh example of
blackberry right Blockbuster you know we
hear how Blackberry they were just
looking because they were very
successful business people love their
their phones people love the keyboard
and I listen I remember Blackberry uh
fans owners because I remember them
saying when the iPhone first came out Ah
that's stupid nobody wants to type on
their phone on the phone screen I
vividly remember some people
personally and blackberry was slow to
move to evolve and you see what happened
to them same thing with Blockbuster so I
think PlayStation of course PlayStation
isn't in the same position they're not
going to go out of business but I just
think they s on their hands a little bit
too long now they're trying to get into
Gamers as a service when the market is
already super
crowded and they don't know how to do it
they don't know how to do a games out
the
service yeah yeah yeah I mean it's hard
to argue with that you can't argue with
that at all honestly it's it's all about
the
timing um if we remember we even even
Xbox we complained about this back in
2015 when Xbox started doing it when
they started the whole play Anywhere
initiative and you can play your games
in one place and play them in others and
I remember Shannon lus came out and said
oh our data doesn't say that it's that
much crossover between PC and console
because they were trying to they trying
to ease this the the console Market say
hey you guys are still important and you
know as time goes on you start seeing
that flip more and more and more and
it's just the fact that Xbox made a
decision to say hey we can't do this in
one place anymore we have to we have to
Branch out we have to do more and that's
the one thing and I said it back in 2017
I was like when everybody was having
issues with Xbox game pass and saying
they couldn't do this and they couldn't
do that and and they won't make money
and I said if anybody can make this make
money it's Microsoft because it's a core
competency of the company the company is
built on services so why wouldn't this
not work for them so PlayStation
just they did not adapt they is not it's
not of I won't even say it's really of
their fault because what was this the
thing when you see money rolling in like
they were seeing in 2017 2018 2019 for
PlayStation 4 it's kind of hard to like
pivot because you see other you see
Nintendo still doing it but the thing is
PlayStation's not nintend PlayStation's
good but they're not
Nintendo Nintendo can still go out there
and have uh a Antiquated ecosystem where
you just buy physical copies of games
and their fans like and there's always
kids growing up that's another thing
people don't realize there's a chance
that once you you're a kid and you will
always probably play games because
that's like one of the best medians to
get you entertained in but there's a
point in your life where you could go in
a different direction you could find
other interests in your life that make
you want to do other things other than
play games Nintendo will always have a
place because there's always a market
for kids to play games once you get to a
certain age you might want to still play
games or you might want to go do
something else and that's where
PlayStation and Xbox sits at and Xbox is
like well we got to find a way to make
the gaming spere bigger than where we
actually Encompass it right now because
like they say it's like 300 million
people that buy consoles on the um on a
generational basis and stuff and they
feel like the console Market is sapped
so now they try to find other ways of
doing that PlayStation Believes In The
Box they believe in the ecosystem they
believe in their wall Garden so they
want to find a way to make that happen
inside of their ecosystem then Jen Ryan
comes in and says no this isn't how it's
G to work if we want if we want to be
competitive in this ever growing
Marketplace we have to make moves we
have to change hit why you see 10 live
games as the service games coming out
hit while you see Bungie being purchased
for $3.6 billion because they don't have
the intuitive they don't have the
expertise to make it happen on their own
they don't all that homegrown stuff goes
out the window when you don't have the
when you don't have the experience no
more right so that's the biggest problem
with PlayStation right now they just
don't have experience in that market and
they don't know how to do it and they're
and this is what we said back in 2018
2019 what happens when PlayStation
realize they have to do what Microsoft
is doing now and that's what they're and
that's whatness it right
now we're witnessing it right now so so
we saw the factions thing we saw Studios
you know pretty much uh being defunded
uh that one devotion Studio whatever it
is Dev deviation you know I think
there's been a lot of changing
PlayStation PL uh plus going up do you
think that they might reverse anything
that Jim Ryan did
did CU to me I think they have to see I
think they'll have to this the thing I
think they have to see it through first
to me I don't think the the ship's on
fire but I think the engine's done and
it can't go any
further and they're trying I don't
here's the thing like you could still
make a lot of
money but not all money's good money
like I like he exchanged money for some
of reputation that was damaged to
PlayStation uh because you know people
well it making your games on PC might
not hurt like your ecosystem but it
definitely devalues your console you
know the PlayStation ecosystem grew
because it went to different audiences
but the PlayStation console devalued uh
you got that on top you got that you got
top of two years of waiting and and no
prominent Studios it does look like you
know you know what we're seeing now
makes me think that they actually
struggled more during the
pandemic than than Xbox it's just we
didn't see it because those games are
supposed to be coming out now I I'm
trying to tell the people that years
ago people kept saying we GNA talk about
the pandemic I'm like PlayStation a have
issue with the pandemic I was like
because PlayStation just happened to
have games that were
ready that was further along in
development than Xbox Xbox like I told
like 2018 when they made all those
purchases of the studios all those
Studios released games within that first
year two years and I kept telling people
I was like listen Xbox ain't gonna have
nothing for a couple of years from those
Studios you see the out of Worlds came
out right around that time so when do
you expect to see outside the grounded
which was 2026 exactly so we kept saying
like dude they're not gonna have the
swap the games that people think they're
going to have until like 2023 2024
because all those students they
purchased literally just got through
releasing Gams and we know especially
with Co and everything happen hit right
and add an extra year so that's why you
don't see something like State of Decay
3 or why you still waiting for hellblade
2 to release because they all went
especially hellblade too because their
all their Studio does is map and you
couldn't even get the studio this you
like that documentary they had when they
were going to Iceland when KY hit bro
they had to stop they stopped everything
pretty much
they started work from home but like you
said they couldn't do any moap right
exactly yeah so that definitely you know
so I mean but it's like and real quick
and that's not even just that you know
we're just seeing some of the struggles
that they had you know Jim Ryan didn't
just pivot towards games of service he
kind of restructured PlayStation towards
it because if you look at the studios he
bought what are they games a service
Studios you didn't really buy any
Studios like remedy that makes the type
of games that a lot a vast majority of
people that love PlayStation make uh you
know when you look at okay if it would
have been different if he's like okay
we're buying Bungie yeah Nexus he bought
Nexus to make PC what year did they buy
um aamc was that 2019 that
was so it was right before it was right
literally right before J over it's
probably literally one of the last who
this bmon dude bro get out of here man
man you lucky this my channel
punk what what what's he saying y'all
know what y'all talking about y'all
capping y'all the Tes on the show okay
Tes on the show trash cheer
man bald I guess we're not kissing
PlayStation but enough get out what
about all the what about all the
PlayStation shows that don't talk about
PlayStation that come over there and
just talk about Xbox on their show and
you know what's funny man like you don't
even got at least I'd respect you a
little more if you had an anime picture
you just got the word b
like can't can't put nothing there man
there's a Google images for a reason
what's going on see that makes me feel
like that's that's a that's a that's one
of those uh you know those accounts that
you know people use to to trash on stuff
that's probably it's probably one of the
PlayStation people that that that that
are too scared to pop up in here and say
something you know that's probably one
of the PlayStation people that that's
like oh they don't want to smoke so they
they're going to sit there and they GNA
stay on the edge and they will come here
with an impersonation you know for bot
oh be for bot so you are a bot so what
what's going on man like I'm confused
tell
me I just wonder I'm just wondering
house markets a live service
Studio that's what I'm saying like how
house last time I know they made single
player
games okay house Mark I'm sorry house
Mark yeah but there isn't that a single
player game studio if I remember
last time I checked they made resun
returnal that's it their games I'm
saying a vast majority of the moves that
Jim Ryan did was for games as sub
surfice it wasn't for single player
games yeah yeah like Haven is doing
doing games out of service hell actually
their big studios was doing you know we
know about naughty dog I believe gorilla
is doing some type of horizon game
multiplayer game yeah I know that's all
I'm saying I'm not saying every step he
moved I'm saying he did slowly build I
mean you you saw you saw the the
projections in the Investments they're
making they when he was around their
projections was like what four years
they had six% of their funding going
towards games as a service 60% yeah yeah
so it's just like that shows it right
there you know it would be different if
he just bought Studios to make those and
he didn't like really you know I'm gonna
buy all these Studios I'm going to buy
Bungie and Bungie's goingon to look at
all these Studios but it's rumored that
Guerilla games making some kind of games
as a service and we don't know if it's
maybe a co-op maybe it's not a
full-blown games as a service yeah uh
there were um there there's rumors that
there was another first party Studio
making up if I remember correctly did
um
did uh was it was St Monica making
something Santa Monica is making one I
just can't cuz
Cory it doesn't look like it was just
Studios that were purchased for that
particular reason and multier yeah
they're making something like
multiplayer I thought they was making a
single player
game so to to me who knows they ain't
telling nobody nothing right so to me
that's it that's an issue because what
what's going to happen is what what
happens when you have 100% of a studio
and you're trying to to make this single
player game or you know the multiplayer
game and the other one starts lagging
behind yeah you're going to you're going
to reallocate people you know you're not
working on this anymore uh you're you're
working on this now uh so it is going to
be interesting and and someone said
um someone said St Monica is making two
single player games uh if they are they
are uh London Studios like out of War
DLC
right yeah that's what they said they
making God War DLC well I don't know
we'll see I guess all right we talked
about that
enough all right so let's let's move on
with this we got the deal
closing uh our life is about finally
starting to uh noriz this deal man let
me get these two super chats real
quick Super Chat from Mingo MC Dickens
sup fellas hey hadock why can't I be
part of the fellas why do I got to be a
separate thing am I not part of the part
of the group
I gotta be independent on my own what's
going on M MC
thickens why is the SC uh screen Pitch
Black in the upper right every so often
I see a couple white show some damn
respect
Mingo show some damn I just I just got
what he me I I what is he talking about
and then and it hit
me show some damn respect
Mingo how dare you Dam man that man said
you need to stop going outside a little
too hot out there for you I work outside
I can't help you do work
outside a little hot out there got a$
five Super Chat from uh stainley uh
Buffington uh the PS5 is devalued yet is
selling faster than the PS4 they went
games with servers to bring a different
revenue streams Colin said this you
disagree Dam I agree but at the same
time yeah baby is that good for the
brand long termwise it works it's
selling better yeah that's all y'all got
it's selling it's selling oh my God the
CLE was buying the PS5
congratulations yeah we see that's
that's the main reason why he's doing
this good casuals congratulations
damn the thing is long term is that
gonna is that gonna matter is that going
to matter because if if they're which
they're selling great you know that slim
is going to sell um but let's be real
man um slim if PS5 don't sell if Sony
don't sell
ps5s they don't sell software flat out
Xbox has another Revenue stream besides
just consoles the games launch day one
on PC and as you see PC like but there's
the games like some Xbox first party
games you saw how GRE Starfield did but
you know know look man y'all have the
sales narrative
continue to to talk that you know what
about y' sales narratives enjoy enjoy
because that's all that's the only
narrative y' I have at this
point but goad we're and we're slowly
inching our way taking that one somebody
said that they're using their PS5 to
play Twitter King has found your base
and we are we are Marching there right
now oh do you speaking of which Addy do
you believe that are they going to be
your app a new console in 20 PlayStation
6 will it be an app by then yeah for
what you know you know you know you are
our our favorite our favorite Lord and
Savior the king he said they're gonna be
an app so do you think it's going to be
an app before it's a PlayStation 6
because you know he said it ain't gonna
be a PlayStation there gonna be a ps6
and then an app oh then an app well I
agree it's gonna be an app at some point
yeah I just want to know who's going to
be right first these guys out here they
they really need to just pay attention I
said this on my podcast last week they
up here focus on Starfield and force of
Motorsport y'all need to focus on
Playstation right now y'all need to
focus on your house don't don't be the
dirty filthy house that's calling the
house across the street dirty and filthy
look at your own house Jim Ryan has got
fired factions is cancelled most likely
cotour cancell deviation game cancell
y'all got the PS5 slim digital that's
going up in price got the PlayStation
Plus that went up price a $30 damn
vertical stand y got 80 y'all need to
focus on Playstation what's going on in
your house they got thank you price went
up they got PlayStation got hacked
Bungie got sued now y'all want to talk
about focus on y'all own house man
that's what y'all need to do that's
right budy did get sued maybe
PlayStation content creators that like
to talk about Xbox all the time will
talk more about PlayStation maybe these
issues be issues I do want to ask I do
want to ask you guys both and I'm glad
I'm here to ask you you know could I
respect both your opinions on this you
don't respect mine I do I talk to you on
the phone all the time so I definitely
respect you and help you with stuff that
people don't even know about but um I
wanted to ask you guys uh about the
leaks that we had got and it's something
that I've been thinking about so
2025 supposed we're getting a brand new
digital series s x and
S now
there's now if you go off thing now Phil
Spencer said this could change he said
stuff has changed I don't know if this
has but do you think that Xbox will be
all digital in
2025 because as of right now if you go
off of those leaked
documents the what is it the I forget
one of them the x is supposed to be
replacing the x that we have now and
they say it's going to be in the Life at
the end of 2025 so that would put us
squarely in an ecosystem where Xbox is
digital only if that was to be the case
what are your guys's
thoughts damn in 2025 that's obviously a
couple years from now I still think this
my opinion that's too early to go fully
All Digital with no option for a a disc
drive I mean I would say even if 90% of
people go digital it's still that 10%
that still
I can't play my games and plus I think
what they'll do is right now the ideal
is to replace it but if they feel like
that digital thing might hit them too
much I think they'll just continue to
produce the series X's that's currently
out now yeah and they just scrap the the
digital X yeah no they'll have the
digital X oh they'll just do
both produce both because if you you
think about it the majority of the
features for the digital uh for the new
digital X dig X for the new Xbox series
X all a lot of those features are just
because it's all digital
like yeah I just thought I I haven't
been on the podcast to ask anybody about
that because when I looked at I was like
I don't hear people talking about it and
I was like because it's a very small
thing in in the fact that he did say
that plans have changed um I do think I
do think that having Activision as a
part of your EOS system probably will
have that change because a lot you know
there's a large amount of people that
still buy Call of Duty on a disc 100%
yeah so I think that might change it
itself but it's just interesting to see
that you know Xbox could be the first
All Digital console we have in 2025 if
the pl stay the same that they are but I
just want to know what your guys's
opinion on not hope it don't come true
because I agree with you D I think it's
little too early littleit too early now
if you tell me next Generation
generation I agree next possibility yeah
exactly do 2028 yeah it's a strong
possibility I think PlayStation opened
up a a door that people are going to go
towards let's let's make an accessible
dis tray we could put in that sucker in
the base system is not GNA have one but
you can buy one for additional cost I
you know what I think you might be right
so you're saying the because the PS5 um
digital well I'm sorry slim well digital
or whatever it comes price system right
but it comes with the option to add a
excuse me and um an uh additional dis
like a us I'm I'm sorry a uh Blu-ray
Drive HD Blu-ray Drive I think that
might be something they might do in the
future all the like default all of the
consoles will be digital but they will
all have that option just in case if you
still have some disc you might have to
pay a little extra for a digital for I
think we'll get to a point where there
won't be a physical version if you want
a digital a physical version they so
bundled units that have the diss tray
with the physical version yeah digital
version Don't DV who who watches those
all these websites we got out here
brother DVDs DVDs baby all these smart
TVs got yeah come on bro one thing they
on Blu-rays feel bad for the people that
got like hundreds of
I mine away DVDs my my friend has
literally wall to walls of and Blu-rays
every time I get rid every time I get
the Blu-ray I always buy the one copy he
a bunch of like anime stuff like anime
Seasons to like everything you could
think of and he's like AJ well that's my
real name for those of you knew my real
name is AJ so he's like I'm a I'm a
I'mma upgrade my my anime collection of
Blu-ray and I'm like oh cool and he's
like do you want my DVD animes I'm like
yes cinem on over like so that man he
better just go ahead and buy him a a Nas
and put the stuff all on there and copy
it to his um copy it to his storage buy
new ones speaking of storage man I
actually went I I bought that two
terabyte um no expansion card because it
was on sale bro it was onale Amazon
best how much I paid one one um was it
180 or something
oh that's not that bad plus I had like
60 Best Buy uh dollars or whatever you
call it oh you got the little you got C
you got your card oh yeah yeah you they
got you got you yeah they got me because
the sale ended tonight bro they got you
for the $200 too didn't they yeah yeah
yeah
yearly I pay a
year I was like man that's if I go here
buy TV for Best Buy I'm buying that $200
thing so I can get that warranty for
free yeah all right let's let's let's
actually talk about so the deal is about
to close guys and someone wants to know
what AJ stands for AR James so deal is
about to close I can confirm that that's
true uh confirm what that that's your
name oh yeah obviously I'm not gonna lie
about it so the deal the deal is
probably going to be closing in the next
week you know um I would say it's it's a
Dale at this point Activision has
literally came out and said they've had
meetings about what what Xbox is going
to be doing when they buy oh they saying
next week so so it's not Friday the 13th
anymore I think the deal is up on the
18th officially so like but they said
that they can announce it Friday though
that's what they were saying I don't
know who know man don't you dare
announce anything like that on Friday
the 13 way
today yeah so I think that that is the
key um you know I want you guys overall
opinion first off are they going to have
their own Bethesda round table
discussion and second off what is your
personal expectations you want for when
this deal is officially
closed will they have another round
table I'm assuming they
will with with who that's the question
with who is like good old Bobby gonna be
there I don't know um I don't know if
they're gonna have that's a good
question CH Bobby don't leave there's a
chance but I I'm D I'm starting to lean
that way a little bit I think he's there
for the go c c Bobby is literally here's
to me if Bobby didn't need to be like if
he was leaving I feel like he wouldn't
even be in these like serious
conversations like like it really be
feeling like he's he's hyping his
soldiers up for
war he might be there bro you're right
about it part of me thinks he's got to
be leaving but the other part of me is
like you know if it came between him
leaving and Microsoft not getting the
Activision Blizzard and King company do
you think they would say like okay no
we're not going to buy you because you
refuse to
leave I don't know man I don't know man
listen Bobby about to get a bag though
he about to get broke off some real
proper I damn that's a good question is
he gonna be gone that's a good question
I don't know how to answer that man it
seem like you made a good point it seems
like he's been talking
he rallied the troops yo yo check this
out we G bring guar hero back you know
this deal is one I be at this point 100%
done um it's just the point when they're
gonna announce it that it's official and
I can't wait I got a video ready to go
this it already recorded I got the
receipts ready to go I just didn't do
the audio portion yet but I'm ready for
um Bobby I don't know Bobby might be out
though I think he's gonna get his bag
and be gone
but then again who knows man what you
think Forte I think they're gonna do one
I think Bobby will be sitting there it's
gonna be awkward as heck but he will be
there Bobby will be there uh Yar will be
there here's the
thing here's the thing is he just there
because he technically is like
controlling that compan right now he's
gonna be he's GNA be there he's GNA be
or is he there because he's going to be
talking at this event because to me if
he's leaving he'll just be there to show
support but he won't say a whole lot
Phil and everyone else will say
something but if he's directing the
conversation in some way shape or form
he ain't going nowh okay that's a good
question now remember at the Bethesda um
Round Table they had I know Pines was
there uh what was there and then they
also had like the marketing person there
the girl she was there and she didn't
really say that much but she was there
she was there and I don't think she said
anything maybe one or two things I think
that's where you're going to see kch
just sitting there he'll have some stuff
that he'll say he'll be he basically
talk about how he's happy to be a part
of Xbox and all this other stuff because
I do think he's gonna stick around but I
do think Yara and I think R Ferguson are
really they're going to be the ones who
gon to be doing a lot more of the
talking um especially since they'll be
more familiar with the ecosystem that
they're going into because they came
from that ecosystem right I think if
Bobby does leave I do think Sarah Bond's
taking his place you do yeah I do
because all you think Sarah would take
it or do you think Sarah do you think
Yar Le Yar probably wouldn't want to
move up I don't I don't think Yar want I
think because I would say Yar would move
up and then she would put they would put
her over over blizzard I think Yar will
stay there as long as they don't like
touch him too much mess with oh yeah
because Yar really did I think Yar was
like when he saw this go down he's like
God dang it I got away and now I gotta
come back right that's pretty much all
when it comes to that man you know uh
yeah we'll see next week I think we'll
be talking about the one and only
conclusion of of the Sacred Movement man
one more week yeah one more week all
right let's talk about the the messy
thing all
right PlayStation has
shown they doing console slim updates
all right and not only are they doing
console slim updates they changing stuff
around you got poor
dis
trays for some reason they changed the
digital version too and and on top of
that they have
raised the the digital edition of the
PlayStation five by $50
so you have the
10 you have the 50 they already raised
it in certain State uh countries so
that's considered a raise maybe we were
infected but a lot of people were and
then you have the 50 that they're raised
to they have technically maybe not in
every region raised it twice uh
apparently a bunch of accessories was
raised in
Japan and it it's what's the funny part
is like we're just now coming off of
like what a month month and a half of
them raising the PlayStation Plus
prices and now we turn around right
before
Spiderman and you just it's it's like
you you're you're walking in there you
see Spider-Man you sitting there waving
coming off the plane like oh we're
finally here and then PlayStation just
shows up at a
note a note he owe us more
money look at didn't the series s get
raised yeah they actually added F 500
gigabytes of storage now I was watching
oh no it's Alex video because I really
didn't realize how much store was
storage was actually
added to what the PlayStation 5
yeah he was said only 175 gigs yeah
that's
yeah I was like are we really people up
here arguing it's like oh yeah it's like
well Xbox raised the price by 50 bucks
and they get and they and they gave you
a one terab I said it was 512 it was 512
and this and it's the other thing too
they don't realize you know going back
if we go off in this doc these leak
documents they did say in 2025 they were
G to come out with a all another system
that was $299 that was one one
terabyte in those documents it does say
that so you know not not you know you
know people arguing about it now but you
know 2025 when that comes back around
you you might be like oh man Xbox is the
by far cheapest console out there $150
cheaper than a
PS5 so you know and then you know let me
um get your Super Chat real quick add it
because it's relevant to this
conversation and don't forget they uh
didn't oh I'm sorry go ahead relative
the F face 23 oh did he just do
two first yeah the first one okay let me
grab that one uh Phase 23 we we'll get
all the super chats but you know Forte
wants this one right because it's Rel
what he's talking about I want to see
that same energy with Microsoft release
his Xbox series X and S slim next year
especially without an OP uh an optional
drive at the same price that they
charged you in 20
so face I love you man first of all
congrat thank you for the $20 man it
really appreciate and the L's appreciate
it too you always help poers and and
your your friend to the realm but uh if
we're going off those League documents
that s that x that you saw that's coming
out in in what 2025 doesn't have a disc
drive but it does have a two terabyte
hard drive in it which is double with
the x is now so if I so if they did go
all digital you would think that well
we're going to charge you the same price
and we're not going to have a disc drive
we're going to double the
space we're going to give you double the
space that you had before for the same
amount of money so it kind of makes
sense whereas with PlayStation first of
all they out here charge you $50 more
for something that literally 150 gigs
that that's not even enough to have Call
of Duty on it by itself or 2K cuz 2K is
170 170 by itself man they're being so
extra here recently when it comes to
PlayStation I expect PlayStation just to
be like hold my
pocket because it's just like can can we
please just submit regardless I I get it
you know we we make the jokes and
everything but this is this might be
above Beyond PlayStation 3 arrogance
like like it's one thing to do one thing
here one thing there but I feel like
they're just doing it over and over
again we're goingon to cancel factions
one week oh we're gonna raise the price
prices on PlayStation the next oh we
ain't done on that yeah that
subscription service that some of you
use and some of you not instead of
making a cheaper or you know give it a
more value we gonna raise that [__]
up you get 30% pay more you
get no no go ahead bro I cut you off go
ahead no no no I was saying it was one
thing though that these guys that's in
the chat that's mentioning well the Xbox
series X S went up five uh $50 it's one
thing you guys are forgetting they're
still making the white Xbox series
s they are the digital PS5 the Slims
they they are
replacing the the ones that's now that's
out there now like once they run run out
of stock if they gave you that black PS
uh Xbox series s with the more
additional for the same price as s and
just sold them both I get it you know
they're gonna make that little extra
money if they can but I do think like
logically for the series s because let's
be real here if you playing on the
series s you got problems um you know
you I it would be nice because if you
really think about it real quick Forte
like I literally just downloaded I I
can't remember what game it was but it
was like 140 gigs I think it was four
you download that game in fortnite you
done that's all you download you done
bro you done how how let me ask y'all
this because this is how I always felt I
always felt like the reason they didn't
make as many of the digital ps5s is
because they were losing money on it
they knew they were losing money on I
agree they knew they were losing money
so that's why they did they they just
had it out there as an option to say we
have this version of a system that you
could get so they can say 3.99 out the
base this is them basically coming back
and saying okay well we sold systems
already we're not going to lose money on
our digital system anymore here it's
going to be the price that it probably
was going to probably be ultimately at
the beginning of the generation 100% And
they said we're going to charge you for
it now which is smart which is smart
because I believe a lot of companies
should do that if you are an early
adopter you should be able to get
whatever it is at that cheaper price now
that that system is established they're
getting they're GNA get you for
everything I don't think it's that I I
think that Xbox and Playstation both
spent way more money during the pandemic
to get those systems manufactured than
we think oh agree with that because I
was told that PlayStation especially
Xbox was dropping Millions just to
prioritize chips right so you know Xbox
it does look like you know they rais
their prices to some degree but
PlayStation is like look man we don't
got that Xbox money I'm G need that back
it's an IOU you
know well I mean just look at there I'm
gonna need you to send
9.99 to this to this address it's got to
be all in ones and I need you to send it
to this address every month on the 5th
well I'm coming for you yeah there their
numbers just didn't work with the $400
price point anymore even if even if
they' kept it at four if you charge
somebody $80 for the drive that's still
$50 less that would be like a better
deal and then buy the drive separately
but they don't want to lose money so
that just kind of lets you know what
their where their profit line really is
it's like okay your profit line on this
system is already marginable and you're
saying that okay well we're going to
raise this one on the bottom end more
because we know we're going to sell more
of that one I mean it is what it is what
it is I mean you could do anything you
want it's their console people are going
to buy it no regardless of whatever we
say but it's just interesting like first
thing I saw when I said I was like yo
they're charging $50 more for a system
that they're not change it isn't a
they're not changing anything really
they're just giving you the ability to
buy a disc drive they're giving it
another spot to be able to hold a disc
drive later so and then they're romly
making all your plates you bought before
you can't even use those anymore so now
all the stuff that comes out later you
have to buy the new plates so guess what
they like they GNA sell you the same
plates just for CH color in four instead
of two so they so anybody that went out
and did this and I was like shout out to
BG I was listening to BG's video VG was
like I got you know he said I got a
digital and I got a physical I don't
which one I want to get rid of and I'm
screaming at the screen like BG don't
get rid of either of them what four just
keep the one you have like I was
interested in getting the slim
PlayStation 5 just say Okay I want a
smaller PlayStation 5 because it is
smaller but the route that they went in
doing it just makes me not want to do it
yeah but you know I feel let me ask you
guys this though like what if you have
the urge to if you got a new new like
PS5 slim and you had the urge to stand
up vertically
you gota pay
$30 so I told you man that $9.99 I
wanted I want to hear every fifth of the
month and it got to be in one it gotta
be that's very
important look I can't get rid of my
PlayStation because that's what I
currently used to work out with so you
know I'm stuck with it all right it's
It's My Curls all right I need it for
them curls those gains are important
health is we all that stuff you know
don't get wrong you do that about 10 15
times of that PlayStation man you
man get
you well at the end of the day when it
comes to PlayStation it's like they'
they've clearly full of it they're full
of themselves right now and you know if
if you guys don't see it at this point
you're not paying attention to maybe you
just don't care D they literally gave
you the stand that nobody that 90% of
the people don't want and I stand they
gave you in the Box use stand they
literally that's what they did let me
let me get these super chats we got a
five5 $2 Super Chat from Spartan 661 the
new PS5 slim is going to overheat faster
mmw what's mmw
stand Modern Warfare Modern Warfare uh
modern I don't know what is that I don't
know
mmw I have no idea make me
wow good I don't know what's up spart
661 how you doing brother $5 Super Chat
for the angry therapist if they go all
digital these consoles better be cheaper
I doubt it God my dude I doubt it they
know you're gonna pay for it they say
they're gonna do it unfortunately true
$5 Super Chat from uh from uh cwee call
wee yep call wee so they did all that
work to make sure you can use your old
game disc backwards compatible All
Digital that makes no sense they'll have
both I think he's talking about when we
were saying you know that Xbox series X
will probably be like the only digital
console I person like or both that's
just me yeah hope so we got a $2 Super
Chat from the angry therapist they pay
Bobby to leave
hopefully you already got a golden
parachute sometimes sometimes it's not
about the money sometimes people they
they stub $20 Super Chat from uh face uh
face two how does he want BK y BK B A
bkny Y Brooklyn New York New York oh
face to Brooklyn New York get out of
here Tom handerson so he far go
everything he leaked right to right so
PS5 Pro is coming next year and if it's
499 even 599 with more power not gonna
be a good look for Xbox next year hey yo
who is this guy son who was this dude
son
son I'm dead ass
bad who was this guy son I'm dead ass B
dead ass
son where someone said is that addict's
real
voice we got the list 22 with the member
chat been member for 32 months man
that's that's amazing conspir uh
conspiracy to raise the price beginning
of J disc versus digital was 10 out of
one now digital versus disc will be 10
to one forcing people to buy the dis uh
drive at $80 actually I have a
conspiracy too and maybe it's it's a lot
more similar I think people will say oh
you know they're going to sell them both
I think they're eventually going to
start not making as many PS5 uh
physicals and getting the digitals so
when you go out get it so you have to
get it because if you look at it they're
getting 50 if you buy that physical I
agree if if you have to get the dis TR
they gonna get 80 they're artificially
raising the price of the PlayStation
that makes sense my 30 buck and guess
what they can sell it as an accessory
and accessories got a what 40 to 60% uh
attachment rate when it comes to revenue
profit right accessories got a $2 Super
Chat from Dragon Knight
77 either Sarah Bond or maybe Lulu will
be in control hey Lulu been capping man
she was capping for a long time over the
last two years so she definitely
deserves it got A5 for rain G4 question
how big will the new p P five box is
beat that's a good question you know
it's funny it's the same price they
didn't want to like make anymore so they
it's like you open it and it's like a
box like it's like a little because they
had like Ed cartons kind of in it yeah
they still put them Ed C it's one in
another yeah hey you know what you know
you talking about the PS I'm still
looking for the dude that that sold me
my damn PS5 [__] spin all that money for
my PS5 what I need to find that dude as
soon as I find him I'mma have some words
with
him
you need to find that guy sodia has
taking a
stand that's a good one just taking a
stand they did they said you get one
stand and not both oh that almost killed
me he almost assassinated
me R that's a good one bro good good
okay okay okay my my head is feeling
better uh Spartan 661 with the $2 Super
Chat
I can make a stand for a PS5 slim with
scrap
wood hey man y'all be mean to the
PlayStation 5 we got a $20 Super from
God Emperor sua King I actually love
that name that that that's dominant name
man I like that yeah it is Ponies are
down bad and PS and PS is down bad Jim
lying crying forced into retirement to
Ryan Ryan got the boot Bungie getting
sued factions cancelled uh 40% price
increase for PS5 hacked twice and now
and now charging them dudes More For
Less that's that's it's the apple way
man oh I love this2 Super Chat from
Spartan 661 mark my word you stands for
mark my word that's what it means every
thought it model in Modern Warfare I to
say I when I said Moder reward I was
like no that don't make
sense shout out to you
smartan
mark yeah I appreciate so you I think
that's pretty much all we don't really
have to go too much into that uh you
know we we we've already been an hour
and 37 once again I want to apologize
for you know starting late you know for
Forte yo where can the people find you
at oh man uh gab Forte YouTube and
Twitter um DPS podcast tomorrow night
it'll be actually on my channel tomorrow
night uh with the homie slow-mo we're
gonna have aam on one of one of the
really cool people from our community to
talk about for yeah yeah she she's huge
at the forza so we're gonna be really
talking about that tomorrow and um you
come watch me make fun of slow-mo like I
always do every week and he'll trying to
make fun of me successful at it exactly
make be successful at it but uh make
sure you um come through hit the like
button hit the Subscribe button on that
and um make sure you U definitely go
check out my man Dirk I love him and I
and I'm the one that he's looking for
that sld him that PlayStation 5 yeah
yeah I got footage man I'm not taking it
back
either and d d what the people find you
at man hey man hope you spam your stuff
in the chat yeah spam my spam it man
spam excuse me so yeah guys uh check out
my
channel I have a podcast tomorrow one
man dark man have some fun I actually
saw uh somebody blame Xbox for
PlayStation uh digital price increase I
think it's one of the Forte homies it's
kind of it's kind of crazy he said he
what like one of your homies uh blame
Xbox not being enough competition so
that's why Sony raised the price of
their PlayStation slim digital man you
gotta do something I guess there would
be some truth behind that but the
problem with that is that could
literally be used against anything like
if literally with that logic you can
blame everything wrong in the World on
Disney because they don't feel like no
one's their competition bro no no
there's no truth to
that he's flat out playing Xbox with
everything the reason I was saying there
is some form of Truth to that because if
Sony doesn't feel like Xbox is a
competition to them they would feel more
comfortable doing this Dum that's crazy
because Jim Ryan was crying all of 2022
I don't know oh I agree I agree we can't
recover $2 from uh face Brooklyn New
York don't care for the slim getting the
ps45 pro next year that's the the one
thing people don't remember you know if
they're if they're increasing the
standard ports how much is that SL that
Pro gonna be 599 bro telling you now
then we got the $5 Super Chat from God
Emperor suffa King PlayStation look like
Spider-Man at the end of Marvel infinity
Wars after the Thanos slap snap I can't
I I don't feel so good Mr stop I don't
feel so I feel so
good
all right so
uh u d is that is that all you got to
say to That's it man you know um I'm you
know I've been working on my um
ABK is official video I have to say I
like how I like I got I've been having a
bunch of
receipts you know after the CMA block I
kind of I might have to delete these
receipts but of course you might have to
delete these receipts to start looking
for your own
yeah we're going straight from from
offensive to now I gotta defend my
receipts listen man I'm looking forward
to D's video because the one thing I
like the most about his video is when
they when when this when it's one of
those agenda videos like this one will
be yeah it always has like a whole bunch
of screenshots and the in the music
playing and oh you listen you already
know it drops to the beat of the of the
whatever he had on the screen I be I be
looking forward I knew so I'm glad that
CU I already know what it's going to be
you already know man first one minute
first minute and 30 seconds gonna be
nothing but receipts on the screen all
right so hey you already know I'm
sending you guys over there to fame
level one uh level one podcast Level One
gaming I call it level one podcast they
got their whole branding revolver level
one go over there
yo addict raid I don't know how you want
to say addict show raid go over there
you know even if you can't sit around
for a while because I know you guys
already been here for like an hour for
it just hit the like button if you go
over there go there hit that like button
and then you know tell them addict sent
you addict dirt and Forte actually just
say that addict show sent you I
appreciate for coming through we'll see
you next
week hey Forte that's pretty